it's Isaiah car here with the USC choses
let's shoot your shot what's been the
best thing about USC so far definitely
the experience just being here football
games as well I mean it's all been fun I
like playing here what's your favorite
subject in school I'm starting to ride a
lot so ride in class if you could play
any other sport besides basketball what
would it be foolball uh I used to play
when I was younger if you could go One V
one with any celebrity who would it be
Chris Brown or Drake who is your NBA
player comparison on the court uh I
heard a little bit of Jason kid I'll say
him for sure what's your least favorite
practice drill rips something like that
okay last but not least if you're trying
to get someone out in horse what would
your go-to shot be I have course shot
first try on
camera told you get in it
ball yeah just like that